pour comprendre la mission canadienne en
afghanistan il faut remonter au 11
septembre 2001 la taxe sur new york les
états unis en tête sous le choc entre
autres avec les forces canadiennes
allaient chasser les taliban hébergeons
afghanistan on allait aussi aider le
pays à se rebâtir construire des écoles
aider les jeunes filles à aller à
l'école
le canada à faire de s'occuper à
l'époque de kandahar au sud une des
provinces les plus durs en 2007 alors
que le débat faisait rage au canada sur
le bien fondé de cette mission alors que
les dépôts yeux revenait au pays
charles dubois caméraman et moi sommes
allés voir dans quelles conditions les
soldats canadiens travaillaient quelle
était la nature de cette mission
justement ce qu'elle avançait comment on
pouvait mesurer sur le terrain les
résultats en cette journée où l'on rend
hommage aux militaires tués ou blessés
lors de ce conflit
nous avons cru important de vous
remontrer une partie de ce reportage qui
a été diffusé d'abord à une heure sur
terre en septembre 2007 pour mesurer
justement le fort prix qu'ont dû payer
bien des militaires 22e ou 6 heures du
matin une journée pas comme les autres
sur la petite base wilson à une
quarantaine de kilomètres de kandahar
dès le lever du soleil les soldats de la
compagnie b de valcartier savent que
leur entraînement et terminer dans
quelques minutes ils avanceront au pays
des talibans
l'adjudant maître mario mercier sera
notre guide pendant cette longue journée
est bien capable je crois qu'il n'est
pas définitivement normal cette première
opération du 22e a été conçu comme une
démonstration de force
une douzaine de véhicules blindés des
chars des camions l'objectif aller
reprendre la montagne de gaulle des gars
à 16 kilomètres de là qu'elles
n'apportent de vingt neuf ans maintenant
ce quadra paul
on est surpris vers 11 heures
l'opération prend toute une autre
tournure au loin les soldats aperçoivent
les femmes les enfants quittant village
vacances qui sont cachés vont venir
indique que peut-être potentiellement
les échoppes des insurgés comme les
militaires les appels qui vont tirer des
tirs de fusils et de mortier provenant
d'une poignée talibans caché derrière
ses murs après 9h va et vient d'avancer
de recul on commande à l'artillerie de
répliquer l'eau froide à ce monde qui va
tomber l'affairé
on a ça l'ombre standard c'est une
grosse moyenne fait cette bataille c'est
une des bonnes
oui c'est gros
la disproportion de moyens frein poignée
de talibans avec leurs mauvais tirs de
mortiers arrive tout de même à stopper
une douzaine de chars véhicules blindés
et des canons modernes sont démontés
sont à gen con est gage de son dallage
son live pour beaucoup d'équipés plus
tôt dans les mêmes conditions
tous nous explique ici que les
américains auraient depuis longtemps
fait appel à l'aviation et bombarder
tout le village canadien ce jour là font
preuve de patience c'est le but d'un
manner préserver leur s'est trouvée
dommages collatéraux continuer la
sécurité après avoir la protection de
7h30 on fonce vers la montagne
le commandant vite les choses bougent
plus rapidement la nervosité est à son
compte
à moins d'un kilomètre le commandant
peut être rassuré at on bien respecté la
montagne ou même moment amplifiant cette
impression d'essoufflement un chant est
la cible de tirs de mortiers
18 heures nous arrivons à 200 mètres de
la montagne
on rappelle tous les chauffeurs de
véhicules de rester dans les traces pour
éviter de rouler sur une mine
alors que nous arrivions au sommet que
je notais mes dernières impressions sur
cette bataille sur cette mission sur
réaliste contre des talibans est visible
alors que jean cercley les mots
perpétuel recommencement
alors que charles et moi en avions assez
vu pour comprendre l'extrême difficulté
de cette mission
alors je me demandais à quoi ressemblera
cette région en février 2009 lors du
départ des canadiens
soudain tout s'est tu étais en un fracas
il
en recul à notre véhicule a frappé une
mine dissimulé sous une épaisse
poussière de montagne le caporal chef
christian duchesne a été éjecté il est
décédé sur place
l'adjudant maître mario mercier
notre guide n'a rien pu voir non plus de
la fin de l'histoire étant placé juste
au-dessus de l'explosion expulsé le
aussi l'interprète afghan des forces
canadiennes est mort en route vers la
base de kandahar
le caporal chef nicolas magnan a été
gravement blessée aux jambes dans le
véhicule
il ne restait que charles et moi sonné
charles a souffert d'une grave fracture
ouverte et a dû être amputé de la jambe
droite sous le genou
ces images sont les siennes et témoigne
de ce besoin d'aller raconter les
histoires même difficile
plus tard cette nuit là les forces
canadiennes ont déclaré que l'opération
militaire avait été un succès que la
montagne avait été reprise aux talibans
c'est vrai mais les soldats de la
compagnie b qui sont arrivées au sommet
se sont fait attaquer pendant dix jours
et ont dû attendre deux semaines avant
que convoi puisse enfin aller les
rechercher
malgré tout la très grande majorité des
soldats rencontrent et croit en cette
mission professeur 20 que si j'étais
dans les mêmes conditions de ce que je
jouais depuis six à manger au carré
même cet écart était nos propres
canadienne a le verbe l'aude en eau qu
on ait dit nettement pense la même chose
ces valeurs on cultive une
l'adjudant maître mario mercier croyait
sa mission
la question est de savoir si la mission
telle que définie lui rendra justice
22e ou 2007 à une quarantaine de
kilomètres de kandahar
une journée pas comme les autres
un mot pour vous dire que charles dubois
mon camarade va bien il travaille en
trois comme cadre si on vous a
représenté ce reportage là c'était aussi
pour souligner on parle et on donne des
chiffres des statistiques 158 soldats
blessés de mort par dont 2000 blessés
si ce qu'ils ont vécu au quotidien
pendant toutes ces années dans le sud de
l'afghanistan une mission extrêmement
difficile où les succès se mesure est
très difficilement cette montagne dont
on parlait il l'avait sécurisé trois
mois avant ils sont retournés et c'est
avec moi
jocelyn coulon jocelyn bonsoir bonsoir
vous êtes je le rappelle des acteurs du
réseau de recherche sur les opérations
de paix en version montréal
vous connaissez bien cette mission je
posais la question en 2007 est ce que la
mission va être à la hauteur du
sacrifice que ces gens là ont donné
comment on peut mesurer l'échec ou la
réussite d'une mission c'est toujours
très difficile de le faire au moment
même où la mission se retire en 2014
parfois faut mesurer sa dans cinq dans
dix ou dans quinze ans parce que tous
les programmes de reconstruction qui
sont mis en oeuvre sur un territoire que
ce soit la mienne ce temps wire prennent
du temps
il vous le savez vous êtes allés dans la
région de kandahar il y a là un barrage
le barrage de dahla et tout son système
d'irrigation
c'est le deuxième plus grand barrage
d'afghanistan construit dans les années
et si le canada qui a entrepris de le
réhabiliter
et ça c'est très important pour un pays
où il ya très peu de terres arables donc
les dizaines de millions de dollars qui
sont investis pour désensabler et
réhabiliter un barrage auront des effets
dans plusieurs années sur l'agriculture
et sur l'économie générale de la région
et de l'afghanistan
ça c'est une mesure du succès alors et
il y en a il y en a dans tout
l'afghanistan aussi parce que n'oubliez
pas que le canada était avec 45 autres
pays sur le terrain donc des avancées
vous parlez du barrage et c'est fort
juste effectivement il ya eu
effectivement un certain nombre d'écoles
même si certaines écoles qui avaient été
battus ont été détruites
ensuite par les talibans mais on n'a pas
régler un problème qui est endémique
dans cette société là c'est à dire une
société presque moyen âgeux sur certains
aspects les talibans sont toujours
présents lors de voiture c'est réglé au
noir la mission est pas accompli dans ce
sens là mais d'où est elle partie
exactement en 2001 qu'est ce qu'il y
avait en afghanistan en 2001 sept cent
mille élèves dans les écoles il y en a
aujourd'hui 7 millions dont trois
millions de filles
donc ça aussi c'est une mesure et ça
aura des effets dans cinq ou dix ans
lorsque toutes ces générations vont
sortir des écoles pour venir y rit dé la
société afghane alors vous parliez des
talibans c'est vrai que ça c'est un
échec le dialogue ou la négociation avec
les talibans mais elle est en cours et
le prochain président qui sera élu dans
quelques semaines puisqu'il ya un
deuxième tour de l'élection ce sera à
lui maintenant de faire la paix avec les
talibans beaucoup de voix s'élèvent pour
dire les occidentaux sont peut-être
partie trop rapidement après avoir payé
un lourd prix en vies humaines en coup
ça coûtait une fortune cette mission-là
le canada et d'autres pays auraient dû
peut-être rester plus longtemps qu'en
pensez vous alors les occidentaux ne se
retire pas complètement
d'abord les américains vont signer ou
s'apprêtent à signer avec le nouveau
gouvernement
retraités sur dix ans pour maintenir
c'est un certain nombre de militaires
sur le terrain le canada par exemple est
engagé dans un programme des 2 300
millions de dollars jusqu'en 2017 pour
continuer justement ses efforts en terme
de purification de l'eau d'éducation de
santé des femmes et des enfants
donc la coalition elle est toujours
présente mais son format militaire est
réduit et son empreinte economic
development talent va se poursuivre est
ce que les forces canadiennes parce que
je le disais en introduction
à l'époque on avait refusé l'irak et on
se sentait un peu obligé de participer
très activement en afghanistan et on a
dû nous on va prendre la province la
plus entre une des plus difficiles dans
le sud du pays kandahar
est-ce que nous étions prêts à cette
bataille en fait nous étions prêts mais
les américains qui avaient occupé cette
partie de l'afghanistan
ce sont eux qui sont partis trouver
qu'il s'agit pas de les blâmer mais tous
ceux à qui vous posez la question vous
diront lorsque les canadiens sont
arrivées dans cette région
ils ont trouvé une religion qui avaient
été laissés complètement à l'abandon
parce que les américains tellement
pressé d'aller en irak qu'ils ont entre
guillemets abandonner l'afghanistan
ils se sont repris lorsqu'obama
augmenter le nombre de troupes sur le
terrain mais il était un peu tard d'une
certaine façon donc à la question et
l'on la pause et exprès comme ça ce que
c'est est-ce que ça en valait toute
cette peine tous ces efforts vous vous
êtes du côté un peu plus positif de
parmi les analystes
oui je pense que ça en valait la peine
et comme je vous le mentionnez en début
d'entrevue la mesure du succès ou de
l'échec on la verra dans cinq dix ou
quinze ans jocelyn coulon je remercie
beaucoup
fais moi le revenu sur notre plateau
pour parler de ça aujourd'hui c'est
important merci infiniment à la
prochaine voir